Obviously, we've spent a pretty good amount
of time around here talking about the assault
on free speech on college campuses.
As I've said before, I believe this strike
against free speech to be one of the biggest
problems we face today as we are breeding
a generation of young people who won't be
equipped to use logic and reason in their
own arguments when they graduate to the real
working world.
The university's misguided use of safe spaces
and trigger warnings, coupled with violent
protests and deplatforming or shouting down
speakers is actually robbing many of these
students of literally the most important thing
they can learn in college...the ability to
think for themselves.
Instead of graduating as fully equipped adults
ready to fight for what they believe in because
they know what they believe in they are being
coddled like children who might crumble at
the mere hearing of an idea that challenges
them.
This inability to debate ideas is leaking
out of the universities and into society at
large.
Celebrities spend all day on Twitter ranting
and raving about topics they don't understand
at all.
Comedians, some of whom I know personally
and really like, have become the screeching
lunatics they're supposed to make fun of.
Politicians talk a lot but don't actually
do a lot, and the rest of us are left here
trying to make some sense of what's going
on.
A great example of this is the Title 9 fiasco
which took root on college campuses over the
past few years.
Title 9 is part of the Education Act of 1972
which states that "No person in the United
States shall, on the basis of sex, be excluded
from participation in, be denied the benefits
of, or be subjected to discrimination under
any education program or activity receiving
Federal financial assistance."
That sounds pretty good right?
What we should be going for here is an even
playing field of equal opportunity.
Title 9 doesn't guarantee equal outcome, which
is where hard work, perseverance and sometimes
luck comes into play, but it does guarantee
that whether you're a man or a woman, you
won't be discriminated based on your sex.
This straight forward law of equal opportunity
changed under the Obama administration when
in 2011 and 2014 he issued new guidelines
on how schools should deal with cases of sexual
assault on campus.
While I believe Obama's intentions were good,
the law in effect circumvented our system
of due process.
The Obama administration's policy used the
preponderance of evidence standard in cases
of sexual assault— not the beyond reasonable
doubt standard — which reduces the burden
of proof on anyone accused of sexual assault.
This was a subtle but powerful change in how
we litigate these cases of sexual assault
on campus and some would argue an outright
violation of the accused's constitutional
rights.
Betsey DeVos, Trump's Education Secretary,
recently rescinded these Obama mandates, and,
judging by the celebrity and comedian critics
out there, Trump and Devos were not only anti
woman, but suddenly pro rape as well.
Christina Hoff Sommers wrote an excellent
piece in the Journal of Higher Education explaining
why removing the Obama guidelines was actually
a win for due process and the constitution,
an article I shared with some of the famous
people I saw ranting about Trump's pro-rape
policy.
Of course nobody responded.
We'll link to Christina's article below for
you to read for yourself.
To unpack Title 9 I'll be talking to author
and Professor Laura Kipnis today, as we unpack
her own story of how Title 9 has affected
her both personally and professionally.
Laura has been in right in the middle of the
Title 9 firestorm and our friends at Learn
Liberty have sent her our way this week.
Knowing what you're talking about is a lot
harder than just screaming about how you feel
about something, but a good education taught
me it's worth the effort...